unless I have some type of portfolio
that I build to supplement the it's a
signal
the problem is we've created I guess
these institutions that people hate to
be in and don't want to be around so
they're happy when they're not doing it
instead of kids being like I can't wait
to go to school tomorrow to do the next
thing like I wake up every day excited
about what I'm gonna build I'm gonna get
done we've transformed you know the
studio in the house what we've we set up
a bunch of rooms were we're setting up
to listen the viewing area so we can
expand the podcast and I wake up excited
for that every day
and if I miss a day I get angry why
don't we instill that in young people
instead they're like oh I have to be
here and like you said they're they're
trying to find the easiest path path
path through this thing to get a piece
of paper they don't even need yes
exactly and I mean this is just another
argument for school choice I mean if
you're interested you're interested in
being there then you're more likely to
show up each day you're more likely to
be satisfied you're more actually you're
more likely to actually learn and you
will be more likely to hire a good
teacher and then yes just it's not just
schools it's unschooling as well you can
have unschooling you can have student
student-centered learning so they just
they can sit around and find things that
they're interested in it could still be
led by parents and and experts as well
but it could we could have a more
student-centered approach I mean like
most schools it's essentially you better
be an interested in English from this
hour to this hour and then right even if
you're in the middle of something very
important and you had an epiphany moment
while the bell just rung and you got to
go to math right now from this hour to
this hour you better be interested in it
but that's not how people learn right
you know when you and I or you or I are
interested in something when we wake up
in the morning we go and we work on that
all day well maybe you don't but we
don't have a bell telling us well you
can't be interested in this anymore and
you better start learning something else
so I think the way that it's set up
today I understand you know yeah why
some people will argue it's like that
for efficiency and this large-scale
schooling and it's not efficient and
yeah especially when people aren't
actually learning so we're pouring more
and more money into this school system
each year I mean since the 1960 after
you adjust for inflation between 1960
and 2017 real spending increased by two
hundred and eighty percent in the United
States and our outcomes have been flat
and schooling has looked the same your
time you know whereas in the private
sector thing
tend to look a lot different and
technology takes over because of those
competitive pressures and those
incentives to do a better job and
provide a better product but it's also
like we don't need you know let me stop
let me go back in time there was a point
in time where a human could could know
everything a human could know everything
humanity knew there was a port in point
in time where you as a person could know
literally the summation of human
knowledge and it wasn't that difficult
but when a time now where everything
specialized because we have so much
technology so much development so many
different fields does it even make sense
to put a kid in school and be like we're
gonna teach you everything and you're
not going to use any of it when you're
an adult or does it make sense to break
into school and say what do what excites
you yeah exactly and like I mean I can
think back to a few things that I've
that I learned every single year
Pythagorean theorem I can tell you all
day and night that a squared plus B
squared equals C squared I can tell you
all day and night that mitochondria are
the powerhouse of the cell but I don't
know I don't need to know that and like
we you know I've read Shakespeare I
don't remember Shakespeare but we read
it you know every year it seems and it's
not like I need that right I mean a lot
of the arguments is that so you can kind
of socialize with other people but I can
socialize with other people about
politics I can socialize about things
I'm actually interested in not these
things that I'm not gonna remember ten
years later so here's here's what
happens in my life
what am I where I am and people want to
know like how do I do what you do and I
the first thing at Thomas don't go to
school because if you wanna know why I
didn't go to school like I dropped out
high school very very early I never
finished so you figured this out way
before I did right I would
I went ten years through post
post-secondary you know I did you see I
did it wrong I didn't figure anything
out I just didn't care I want to do what
I feel like doing everyone else is
stupid that's how that's how I've always
viewed it so I end up I play music I
skateboard and there have been a few
jobs in my life that have led me
perfectly to this point so I
skateboarding we would film and we would
edit videos and so we did that for fun
that was part of the culture I started
working for nonprofits which got me well
actually it was music and punk rock as
part of skateboarding which got me more
injured in politics and then I started
working for round profits because of
that but I was doing fundraising which
very quickly you know kicked me out of
the nest and made me have to start
talking to people
strangers get confident now otherwise
you're not gonna survive in this
industry and it was also sales so you
combine these things you combine that
with my you know desire for adventure
and all these things come together and
put me in this position where you know
really everything I do is a combination
of all the things I've done throughout
my life and it's led me to a point where
I've become successful that's the key to
succeeding I think too many people will
look at what someone else is doing and
be like I just want to be them instead
of I want to be me
so I think it's a problem of schools and
I think another issue is a lot of people
will just think about you know a lot of
a lot of growing up for me at least a
lot of people would be like well what do
you want to do when you grow up and it's
like I don't know and like you would
have asked like ten year old me I
wouldn't say that I was gonna be on Tim
Castes show right now talking about
school choice I didn't know what school
choice was so exactly a lot of this is
the discovery process that I don't think
the traditional system deals with really
well because you know the way the way
that the traditional system tries to
deal with is to just throw all this
useless information at you and and have
you jumped through all these hoops and
memorized a lot of things and I was
actually really good with school because
I have a pretty good memory and I you
know and I got really good grades but it
doesn't I didn't I don't use a lot of
that stuff so what you're saying is
abolish school I'm not kidding I'm not
saying that now I I might say that but
the thing that I want to do is just for
people to have the choice and I think
that if people had the choice that would
lead to a world where we have a lot more
unschooling and homeschooling co-ops
because you don't have to pay for a lot
of the fixed costs and you can but you
know just pay for the you can get the
best experts and if you if the if you
get your allotted $15,000 per year you
can afford a pretty good homeschooling
co-op organization if you can get you
know 20 30 kids families together or
kids together you can afford some really
top-notch experts to help your student
your children learn so I just want
people to pick I'm not gonna say abolish
schooling but I think I think that we
would we would end up in a world where
we'd have a lot less schooling if people
had their their own choices in the
matter well what do you feel about
truancy laws yeah I mean that's that's
an issue right you know if I think the
responsibility should be more so on the
teachers right if you're
sending a kid to a school and they don't
and the kid doesn't want to be there
there's a deeper issue there that the
school system needs to address and I
think again that's another argument for
school choice if the kid doesn't want to
be there well we should allow them to be
somewhere that they want to be at school
that they're actually interested in and
like if you look at the most recent DC
Opportunity Scholarship about your
program they have out there they
actually found an increase in safety
satisfaction and attendance so it just
goes to show when people are actually
choosing a school that they want they're
more likely to show up each day so you
can get you can get rid of this truancy
issue by just providing a product that
is actually that kids actually actually
want one to attend and if the parents
want them to be there as well they'll
help make sure that their kids are in
school I think there's two words that
explains the problem and it's school
sucks and like every kid says it and
we've done nothing to rectify that
problem we have any miserable kids they
think it sucks why is that why can't we
create something where you know and then
I think it's because people don't like
to be compelled to do things like even
if you have a high quality school you
can look back and say school sucks
because you didn't you didn't explicitly
choose that particular school but I
think if people explicitly choose it
they get buy-in right and especially if
it's a school that they're interested in
like I went to a magnet school it's
still government-run but it was
communications focused and I actually
got to choose that so I felt bought in
to the school culture specialized
mission and I actually wanted to be
there I didn't I didn't skip class until
senior year that's when I started
skipping I don't want to be in school
and I walked out and I stopped going
yeah and that was it you know I when I
stopped going it was basically I had a
day where I just thought to myself I
would rather not go to this school and
that's it I would rather do literally
anything else they can lock me up for
truancy that would be better and more
more bearable than whatever this is and
we should be looking into what's causing
the truancy right people aren't kids
aren't just not showing up for no reason
right there's there's a reason and it
could be school sucks
but there's there's a lot of different
aspects to that it could because their
teachers are just showing them in front
of a TV all day and not actually
teaching them but it could be deeper
than that it abuse
yeah there's a lot of abuse going on in
public schools the United States doesn't
mean it doesn't happen in private
schools or charter schools as well but
you know this is happening and at least
with the private school you can vote
with your feet and take your kid
elsewhere a charter school you can do
the same thing you can vote with your
feet and take your kid elsewhere but
with most systems your residential e
assigned to a school and if there is
instances of abuse or bullying you're
pretty much stuck there right but you
know places like Florida they have a
hope scholarship program if you're a
victim of bullying you can use you
automatically after doing some paperwork
you caught off qualify for a hope
scholarship really and you can take that
to another school because you're a
victim of bullying so that's another
again another argument for school choice
and you know it and it just encapsulates
this idea of school sucks but right
there's no there's a lot of different
reasons why schools can suck and it's
not only measured in a standardized test
score and it doesn't feel like
anything's being done about it
it never does you know it's like since I
was a kid since oh people all of them me
were kids it doesn't seem like
anything's being done about it yeah I
just saw a I just tweeted something out
today if anybody wants to go look
through my Twitter feed but there was a
story in Houston Texas in a school where
a kid got sent - yeah I think they were
like helicoptered into a hospital
because they and they had to get
stitches on their head because there was
an altercation between them and the
teacher over a juice box so like no kid
should be forced into that type of
unsafe environment or abusive
environment well they should just be
able to leave in a lot of times the the
employees in the system they may get a
slap on the wrist or they may
essentially get assigned to another area
but a lot of times they don't get fired
even in these extreme circumstances
where they're actually harming kids
basically did you hear about what's got
what what's going on in Chicago with
solitary confinement for kids yeah yeah
well that's another problem if I find
out my kid was locked in solitary I'm
taking that kid now no matter what yeah
it's essentially a prison like
environment you know that's that's
traumatizing I mean there's there's
actually been studies and I don't know
what the cause is specifically of this
but there have been peer-reviewed
studies that and I think there was
Harvard researchers that did the most
recent one that linked the calendar year
of the school year to mental health
visits for
student age population so it could be
because they're facing bullying in
school it could be because they're being
locked in rooms all day because that's
the school's policy it could be that
they just don't like going to school and
they they want to be doing something
else but there's a lot more mental
health issues Minh the calendar year and
I also found with Angela Dill's from
Western Carolina University that when
states enact charter school walls teen
suicide rates actually tend to reduce
interest and we actually found that
private school students after
controlling for a bunch of differences
in their family characteristics and the
student characteristics that in the long
run students who go to private schools
rather than public schools tend to have
fewer mental health issues and by the
time they're around thirty years of age
we'll also think about if you're if
you're in a school and you have a pack
of mean people necessarily bullying but
you're embarrassed no one likes you and
you can switch schools
just by easily I mean it's gotta be a
load off someone's back like a fresh
start a new opportunity maybe they don't
just they're not comfortable you can't
just keep forcing someone to go
somewhere where they're they're
constantly under stress and panic and
and and you know what I mean yeah I mean
a lot of this is just the culture of the
school like a and in my school for
example I played football so I was one
of the cool kids right in Texas that was
the thing you were cool if you played
sports but if you were like into arts or
whatever you weren't as cool but in my
magnet school if you were into arts we
were communications art school you were
one of the cool kids so like if you can
select into schools where you you have
similar interests with the other
students maybe in art school then you
know that would you would be looked at
as a cool kid and that can have
obviously huge bought positive effects
on your mental well-being in the short
run and the long run you know it always
seemed like it in all sorts of things it
seems like the things that really do
benefit kids is not the school because
the school is this rigid boring system
but the extra curricular things that a
football for instance but also you know
for me growing up it was a general
community around music card games comic
books and skateboarding so all of a
sudden you know for me skateboarding
I've talked about it before but it was
probably the greatest educational system
I've ever been through for teaching how
the real world works especially because
when you go to a skate park and you're
fifteen year-old kid you've got a 30
year old guy talking about politics and
money and business and you learned that
now I'll tell you what man if we took a
50 you know 15 year-old kids like high
school kids and put them in any adult
situation so so here's the thing like
where can a kid really be around adults
who can teach them and share knowledge
I mean skate parks are the easiest thing
because you share that that that's sport
I mean or even on the basketball court
the thing about skateboarding that's
interesting though is that it's it's
semi active so there's downtime in
between when you are skating so you
might sit down on a ledge while you're
while someone else is doing something
and then you have this guy next to you
is 40 and he's like I got divorced today
man and here's on the courts work let me
tell you and you're sitting there
learning all this stuff about divorce
court you're learning about a guy says
like I started a t-shirt business yeah I
filed LLC you threw LegalZoom and you're
like what's that but when you're in
school they're like a squared plus B
squared equals C squared what's in the
mitochondria powerhouse of the cell they
and they always taught you that
mitochondria is the powerhouse of the
cell but it's actually our right because
mitochondria is plural so it should be
hard but I always repeat is because
that's what they say and most people
well but Carey McDonald who I talked
about earlier who talks a lot about
unschooled very interesting similarity
is that she also talks about her son at
a very young age is very interested in
skateboarding and how he learns how to
socialize at the skatepark so similar to
your story and yeah a lot of people talk
about well we need to send kids to
public school so that they can socialize
well you can do you can socialize in
other ways and there's a lot of negative
aspects to socialization at school you
can be exposed to all this bullying and
peer pressure and fighting you know and
that can be incentivized the wrong type
of socialization could be incentivized
to just you know in my middle school
there's a lot of gang activity going on
a lot of drug act so Lee I mean that
happens at all types of schools I won't
say that it doesn't happen everywhere
but it tends to happen more more often
in schools that don't have a strong
incentive to have a better school
culture I think it's a bunch of people
who don't want to be in a place who are
stressed out and angry and finding ways
to lash out and somehow deal with what's
going on around them as opposed to a
place where someone would choose to be I
couldn't imagine someone like it happens
probably but man I couldn't imagine
someone being bullied at a skate park
it's just no way
or or or a comic book shop or you know
yeah and things I was into I mean I
think the one of the main differences is
there is when you're in the traditional
public school system you're just grouped
based on what how old you are and where
you live and then you're all stuck into
a building together and you're pretty
much it's forced socialization right
whereas at the skate park you get people
from different age groups different
interests but you have a commonality and
that you all you guys all like to skate
and so you can learn from older
individuals and and that I mean I think
you typically want kids to learn how to
be when they grow up right but when you
warehouse them with a bunch of other
kids that are just their age a bunch of
kids their age they they learn a lot of
negative behaviors yeah so you want role
models right right but other people that
are your age might not be the right role
models especially when they're picking
on you but then think about what
teachers are they're not someone who's
supposed to be your friend and a mentor
they're just a stodgy employee in there
who's like reading a book and thence got
the answer sheet in front of them that's
the that's that and so the kids view
them as others as outsiders there was
there was there was an interesting
moment in my life where I had one
teacher who spoke to me like like a
friend would speak to me like
criticizing me in a way so I was I was
goofing off and they said something that
just was not what a teacher would say it
was like something another eighth grade
girl would have said to me nah it was
like just it kind of an insult and I was
like well my teacher just insulted me in
a weird way no no it was like I was
doing something stupid I was I was I was
like you know just goofing off saying
dumb things and like you know play
punching my friends and then they said
something snarky and like condescending
in a way that teachers normally would
never do and it was kind of interesting
that finally but it was an adult it was
it was it was interesting it was it I
you know it was an adult teaching you
the wrong way to act no no no no no this
is a positive thing
oh where I finally felt like they were
treating me like a regular person as
opposed to treating me like an object in
the back of the room that needs to be
you know dealt with for the day like
that this particular teacher never did
that to me but for the most part all the
teach III would have there were always
it's hard to explain the teachers were
always treating me like a [ __ ] another
something to be dismissed just
they're waste of my time I don't want to
be here I don't wanna do this and then
one teacher treated me more so like a
regular person would have treated me and
that was like a weird thing and that was
there was only like two teachers who I
ever had who did that and so ultimately
I thought school is a trash waste of
time and it's partly because the adults
I had been around my family you know
would have friends over and stuff and so
I'd hear normal adult conversations like
oh I'm sure a lot of kids did well my
family also opened a business so I had
to work I experienced how the business
was run was for a couple years
the adults sitting around complaining
about politics and stuff like that was I
was exposed to all of that and then as I
got older I just viewed so there were
there were key moments that often
reference in terms of why I think school
is complete trash and the first one was
I remember being a little kid and coming
home well excited I get asked what did
you learn in school today
Christopher Columbus discovered America
well know Leif Eriksson you know he's my
mom Leif Eriksson was was in the
discovered the Americas a thousand years
before Christopher Columbus we know that
now and I was like oh and she was like
but I mean if you want to get technical
there were already people here right so
I'd want to argue who discovered from a
European perspective the Europeans first
discovered North America arguably Leif
Ericson but then in terms of
colonization and the expansion it was
Christopher Columbus and my mom just
tells me the stuff and I was like why
don't they just tell me that could they
think you're stupid when you get older
they'll teach you these things so I grew
up with you know parents who are
constantly teaching explaining to me
explaining things to me my mom
homeschooled me before I started
kindergarten and then I get to school
and it's lies condescending behavior
insults you know like I had a math
teacher who demanded that I do math the
way they dictate ooh I could do in my
head and so it was very challenging for
me when I'm like I know the answer and
they're like but do the formula and I'm
like the formula is it's in my head and
I just know it 50% of the answer is
showing your work right exactly get it
right because they don't they don't they
don't actually care to teach you how to
solve the problem it's they want you to
follow what the book says do it or else
and so when I said I don't understand
why you would want me to waste my time I
got detention and so I was like this was
when I was in eighth grade I was like I
don't care about you people anymore
you're you're just you're full of it you
have no explanation for why
do what you do you've done nothing but
waste my time and lie to me and if I
really if my goal was really to solve
this problem I would do it my way not
your way and so that was it I was I was
told but don't worry go to high school
it's so much different after two months
I was like nope I'm done out you
couldn't come and arrest me for truancy
I don't care what you do blame my
parents I'm done I'm not doing it you
can't make me and so then we ended up
doing a correspondence thing and I was
out and I never finished that either cuz
I was like I'm not gonna waste my time
every day it's the stupidest thing you
want me to take a piece of paper you
want me to look at the answer sheet like
I hope I can write the answers down it's
it's it's insane and stupid none of this
makes sense
and so I just said nah I'm done thanks
for checking out this segment from the
Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
every Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you